George Osborne has a message for you a
message for all of us he's going to keep
it simple he is going to hammer it home
the long-term economic plan is working
he will be able to lay out a picture of
what looks like robust and strengthening
growth the sort of numbers that here in
the city are music to people's ears I
think confidence is certainly improved
there's definitely a spring in people
step certainly more than there was in
the past I wouldn't be surprised to see
economic growth continuing people to get
more optimistic as time goes by it's all
very well winning plaudits from citi
analysts and traders but they're not the
ones who are going to win George Osborne
re-election so we're going to head out
of the city to the sort of marginal seat
the Tories just have to be taking let's
find out how the Chancellor's good news
is going down in Harlow after years in
labor hands Harlow when Tory in 2010 the
majority of nearly 5,000 is not such a
very thin blue line it means labour need
a solid swing of five point six percent
to win if the Tory message isn't working
in Harlow they're in deep trouble
nationally we are now approaching
hallowed times after the Chancellor no
one's influence has been more closely
reflected in budget after budget than
harlow's current MP Robert Halfon
campaign to curb fuel duty has had a
massive impact on the government's
approach to cost of living I can assure
you that if fuel duty had gone up i
guaranteed there'd be people out there
with their pitchforks because it would
have been unsustainable and I think the
freeze on fuel duty the government
deserve a lot of credit on that of
course I'd like them to do more of
course I would but on Harlow High Street
gratitude is in short supply the
Chancellor says the economy is on the
up-and-up are you feeling it no no why
not cuz I've got a little girl my money
is getting cut and I just don't think
it's fair I think it's gone worse how
come well everything you've wherever you
go near where they're saying you're
gonna get this you're gonna get that and
it's costing you an arm and a leg
struggle
I'm a single mom and I find it very hard
very very hard well nothing's changed
just now I nothing at all I suppose if I
we're not better off for anything now
after that Labor's lines almost right
themselves 6,000 people in the housing
waiting list here there's people really
struggling to find homes we are saying
that we'd build 250,000 homes across the
country people need change now so I
think that they're not ready or willing
to wait for us borns long-term economic
plan the political arguments are very
stuck right at the moment and it's true
that the government's good news
narrative does feel a world away from
what many people are experiencing in
places like this it may be a long-term
plan the Chancellor has but he hasn't
really got a long time to turn that
around Joey Jones Sky News Harlow